le voilà m enfin j'attendais ce jour
depuis si longtemps
grâce à ses formats effet que forgée par
les anciens je vais plonger le monde des
humains dans les ténèbres et le chaos
ne rigolez pas c'est non vous rigolez
pas là bon je vous cache pas que je suis
un peu déçu parce que vous allez à
battre les ténèbres et le chaos c'est ça
oui oui mais voilà bah ça par exemple ça
dérange pas du tout parce que qui dit
ténèbres du brouillard qui dit
brouillard dit humidité qui dit me dit
est dit infiltration enfin bref on va
encore se peler les miches déjà posté
devant nous on sera tout puissant
j'aimerais tellement des torches
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont la foutue
façonniers passe la moitié du temps
fermée de façon et les monstres à on n'y
avait pas pensé ou l'autre ça fait bien
plus salée monde quand même et puis
c'est pour les torches qui vont les
arrêter a c'est sûr mais nous on
n'arrive pas à les arrêter
oui pour le dressage journée sur une
piste mais c'est ça ce que faisait
philippe ce matin c'est ça d'accord eh
ben il est mort et qui se confirme en
fait de la glace si le super idée ça à
la glace alors je n'y pensais même quand
même parce que regarder ça c'est un
sceptre de ténèbres c'est un set de
glace donc du coup c'est le genre de
truc vous tester un pouvoir qui était
pas prévu la bats à fait indépendant
mais l'accord cas j'ai compris en fait
vous n'êtes pas capables de régner sur
le monde de glace narnia évidemment que
ce carburant ne pas savoir c'est que je
suis capable de le verser jusque là me
chercher je suis prêt
karine fermer sa gueule surtout mais
c'est pas possible pourquoi j'écoute
inspire jeu mais enfin la main sur un
truc qui va me permettre de régner sur
les chemins vous suivez une place pas
besoin d'objets magiques et de bidules à
la con non vous ce qui vous caractérise
c'est le moi je le courage voilà mais
c'est moi qui commande
et puis c'est vous qui commande et ça
fait un massacre ça va être un massacre
va maintenant rouler m'a maintenu les
droits tv canal non cette fois